hi i'm danny ceo and welcome to a new
episode of do
just one thing
and you know what the motto is it's
bananas
and what we're talking about today is
one of my favorite fruits but we're not
talking about the fruit inside of the
peel
we're actually talking about banana peel
so
believe it or not banana peel is edible
and if you go online you can find a
whole assortment of crazy
delicious recipes that use the banana
peel so what we're going to make today
is something called banana peel tea and
it's a one
step recipe that is delicious and it's
going to be
something that i think will become your
favorite sleepy time
bedtime tea to drink every single night
so first and foremost you want to
wash the bananas so make sure there's no
dirt no chemicals nothing on the outside
that's going to really
impact the taste of your tea and what i
like to do is first
eat the fruits and then i take one
banana peel so this is a fresh banana
peel and so if i have the banana in the
morning
what i'll do is i'll actually just put
it in a teacup just like this
and i fill it up all the way on the
inside you can cut it in half if it's a
smaller cup
and then it's as simple as this taking
hot water
and pouring it all over the banana peel
you're steeping it you're making a
regular tea and the funny thing about
banana peel tea
is that it doesn't taste like bananas
it's kind of a beautiful
herbal slightly sweet tea
and the reason that i love banana peel
tea is that if you think about it
bananas are high in potassium and
magnesium so this is infusing a ton of
potassium but also the magnesium
which is known to really help with aches
and pains
so if you really want to have the best
sleep of your life i highly suggest
making a little banana peel tea steep it
for about five to ten minutes and then
take out your banana peel and what i
like to do
is also dress it up so you can add a
splash
of your favorite milk or in this case
i'm using
a macadamia nut milk a little splash of
honey
if you want to do agave syrup or brown
sugar and then all you have to do
is enjoy
mmm really really good don't forget if
you want to tag this banana peel tea
recipe in your social media
use the drew barrymore show in your tag
and also be sure to check out more
videos and ideas and recipes at the
jukeberrymart thejuveberrymartshow.com
plus
be sure to pick up my magazine
naturallydannyco
now on newsstands